and or
you know, surprised when
chat GPT has really popped in the last few months,
yes, I definitely thought it was great, I have to
say, I
quickly logged in and played a bit
and yes, we know
training data up to September last
year and then we also know that it was
of course American-influenced, that means
a lot of what I entered that I
knew and then nothing at all was
a bit sad, but e.g.
I asked about the geopolitical
conflict with China and I found
the answer really good
differentiated so it was to say yes,
we have a differentiated
relationship with China because on the one
hand there is a rival on the other
hand we are also
very closely linked to the supply chains, which
means that a single bling is not
that easy  not bad so
that was a differentiated answer
I have to say you are not afraid I
mean all the experts from SAM Oldman
who is behind the Open or
Elon Musk who also financed it at the beginning
they say that they as one  of the
really big threats now,
apart from the nuclear war and and
somehow in the virus say
the greatest danger to humanity
actually yes of course I have also
seen person of interest and all these films and of course I know this
scenario the other way round I have to say I
did my doctorate  neural network
doctorate programmed i.e. i
have an artificial intelligence that's what
it's called today i
built a programmed giant simulator
and dealt with it in my doctorate
and saw the power of it
and you're probably asking the
wrong one
i sometimes say i love  Yes,
technology, I love all of that and um, and
that's why I believe that there
are great opportunities in it, of course,
atoms, energy always has a
downtime and we have to get it under control
as humanity,
but first of all I believe
that innovations have potential
a positive thing, so somehow always
said, I do
n't think it will come that quickly that
it could really become a danger,
so then somehow
machine programming can then
fight against human beings or as
if it's all so far in the
future despite the chat  GP progress
so all of this
is not possible for years or decades, yes, although we
of course also know that exponential
development tends to be very, very slow at the beginning, yes,
so I don’t see it and I
actually believe that these things
can still be controllable, but  Yes,
there is a theoretical potential in every technology,
but when I look at
the development and GPT makes
a lot of things really
exciting, so when you see which
different learning algorithms
have been linked, so to speak, so that
this machine has become so good, then
that is impressive  but in the end
she produces a text and you
also know the examples of what was then
asked about Badoo as
French President and so on, of
course a lot of
nonsense comes out of it, I think he that the
danger lies in that and that is the real
debate  this leads us back to what
we tried to initiate in digitalrad,
namely the question of how can
we all educate ourselves how
do we
actually
deal with this information
that worries me a lot more and so
it's more of a
democratic challenge if you like
or a social challenge,
not so much that I think
the machines control it now and
I don't think so, but that's why
teaching our children not everything
what is on the internet is true not
everything that jetp will say is correct
and but how do you find out and how do
you form your own
opinion how do you form your own
facts how do you actually do it
and I think that is the real
challenge  a bit satisfied
with the type of regulation is currently
so there is also a look at
the big platforms there's been there for
decades the question is or at
least ten years the question is
it really
shouldn't we have to look at it any longer
not  maybe
the big platforms now, keyword
cyber, have helped to
unveil democracy to a certain extent by
suddenly having foreign actors
in election campaigns and stuff like that,
yes, I think we probably have to get
a little closer via the stack,
so I think that  what is
actually happening with Twitter and come with
many of these networks that
is really really difficult and also
a danger and we should
actually talk about it again how
we deal with it because they
are not publishers and so on and so on
all the problems  you've already
discussed it several times, so when we're at the
top of the stack it
really worries me because the
differentiation is no longer there
and also, as I said, armor
that would be a topic, we can
talk about it for hours and really
but then no one takes that time anymore,
so there is
no need to tinker with the topic of
discourse, we can do more about our platform,
we can do more, so how can we
really have discourses again
that are differentiated, that
are respectful, that are also fun
feel like it today oh yeah it's
really complicated but I want
to understand that the first consideration is to
make links and then to fall into something
first to reject or
like or dislike us or whatever
if we go deeper so that's
on the cloud  Going stack there is
actually more of a question I think
that has made many more secure
here I think it is actually
the question we make our
dependencies and how can we
prevent login effects that we currently have so how can we
actually because you can yes  de facto
not switching at the moment and also because of
the equestries it is also very expensive to move
your data away again because
I think we have to
go from Amazon to Google in terms of competition law plus
the fact that they are working their way up the stack
and are not
just trying  Logically not offering the service cloud, so
to speak, but
then the platform is the whole tool world
but then also the data above it and
I think we have to deal with that from a
perspective of sovereignty and from
a
perspective of competition that
happens to some extent,
I think we have to get better
and because the original question was yes,
how do I look at the regulation, I
think some things are good and right in the beginning,
but and that's what I
said before, we ca
n't just be world champions in regulation
and I often miss Germany in Europe
the opposite side the
innovation side the experimental side
the side that says so yes we
regulate but for example AI we
already have an AI regulation now not
with the second one but please let us
first develop AI solutions that
can keep up that are really so
innovative and there
The USA has us, but China has us too, because
image recognition has already
lagged behind and I think it would be
more important to look at where we can
develop intelligent solutions
certain things, how
you mean it, for example this
chip development, again because
my line perspective on it seems to
be so difficult, certain
areas that then obviously a
country like Taiwan
is almost more attractive to please and you seem to be able to
get this boost technology
building it yourself
was just not
possible and somehow I would have
thought that China would get
everything done, they are super smart and build
it, but apparently there are certain
technologies that even China can use all the
resources  can't build and where they
are years ago
is about surprising for you yes,
especially in the chip area it's
not surprising for me because we're
back to the physical world, it
's just incredibly complicated when
we go to the small structures, well,
everything  what I know
is ten nanometers below or now at the very
cutting edge 5 or even smaller that
's just incredibly complicated and
the second thing is that the USA has always more
or less clearly and openly said
they have the strategic goal of
China  up to two chip generations
behind and him and China also
quite systematically and that has just
happened
again with new
acts that they
just don't get supplier products, so to speak, that
means they are regulated and even
partly extraterritorial, that means that
they  So ASML Netherlands
also say that you can no longer deliver if you
do things with us, you can no
longer deliver to China and that
keeps China at the back the question is
and that is a strategic question that
has been the case in the last 12 to 24 months
The
USA-China conflict has become very much more
intense and the question is will this
lead to the Chinese now
saying oh Enite double down and then
really trying
this race again in a completely different way and
then throwing something at it  so
even more than before or so it will
lead to them catching up and
what does that mean then
or will they always be one or
two generations behind so in that respect it
's not surprising that they
haven't caught up yet but I'm
unsure what strategically how now  that
continues now if they
took Taiwan, which
would probably be possible without any problems with the
military force, then there is
the central factory or the entire
company
and this year was behind, so
I don't think it's that easy,
Taiwan is also individual  an island
with native structures, plus that the
USA has also made far-reaching commitments
and also delivered weapons,
plus that Taiwan itself is
now a well-fortified
military shipyard, by the way, also a well-fortified
democracy, democracy ranking is
now a very eight or so am
now  not quite sure very high low
the country so i think
it's not that easy just that the chinese
army from what the experts say
and here i can only quote that they
say they are not ready for
a large scale invasion yet
small strikes, so to speak,
but make a large-scale invasion because
the experts will say they are still around
24 months away but and do you have
a completely legitimate question what does
the long-term or medium-term
scenario look like Dennis and also the party
and especially the first people have
always said that in  his
term of office during his lifetime, but I think it is coming
out himself in the meantime,
he will achieve the reunification of metal
goods and the Chinese people
are very nationalistic and very
patriotic, which means they want that
too and vice versa, Taiwan has drifted further and further away
and is also drifting further and
further away  is becoming more and more Western
as a democracy and is expanding its own
structures with the support of
the USA but also many other countries
because it has an incredibly
important geostrategic location next to TSMC that is like
this picture that is like the
aircraft carrier that there that that that that
swims there and
in this respect there are really
forces that are drifting apart China with
a clear declaration of intent
and vice versa Tai were also with a
small
how the game ends that it is unclear
especially if we look beyond 24 25
I don't know and there is the
scenario that will be closed at some point  there is a
conflict and maybe even
an armed conflict that
is in any case not unrealistic
and not improbable
and that is of course something
that is then that is more
threatening than even now just no
war or something like that
well if you  to Germany, for
example, if we lead to a confrontation, to
an open war,
so there are many escalation levels,
so don't get me wrong, so it's also possible
that there are only
attempts, so to speak, and then there is
deterrence again and then divided
you don't even know how this
will continue, it's also possible that China has
no idea how the curve
will continue, that if
economic growth continues to decline,
that the priorities are back in the country,
so there are many, many
unknowns, it can go in many, many ways
also with the USA, by the way, but in
the scenario, which is at least not
unrealistic, there would be an
armed conflict, an open warlike
conflict, of course, then there would be
a big world war between China and
the USA,
as I said, there are many unknowns